[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__] this
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
I'm trying to tell you
I say it all the time Doubt Me
Oh Jack Smith
what a [__] nightmare for Republicans
this guy's gonna be absolutely a [__]
nightmare for republicans
I don't know if you heard the news we're
going to get into a line of news stories
there's a lot of [__] going on today a
lot of Republican [__] boxes out there
as always to keep track of uh JD Vance
dewine Trump the Santos Nikki Haley just
to name a few those are a few there's a
couple Jim Jordan Ted Cruz I mean
now the list always seems to be the same
and they always seem to be these real
America First Nazis in the real first
real America First Nazi party
um a bunch of [__] fascists but uh
let's let's get to the the felony
fascist
uh Donald Trump
I I was telling you this for a long time
the Justice is coming it's coming
and it appears as if Jack Smith's middle
name is [__] Justice maybe that's his
real first name Jack's just like a
nickname for justice I don't know
beats the [__] out of me I really don't
give a [__] what his name is
key is is that Jack Smith as a
prosecutor
is normally used to Prosecuting
Prosecuting war criminals which I don't
I don't know if you um understand how
War crime works but normally War crime
is that you have a certain power over
people and you use that power to commit
human atrocities
Jack Smith is used to Prosecuting those
people you think he's [__] scared of
that [__] ass [__] down in Mar-A-Lago
give me a [__] break
you think you think he he is going to
take marching orders from Merrick
Garland
the word is is that he he is absolutely
not communicating any of these steps to
Merrick Garland mayor Garland is
separate for separated from this issue
at this point
on matters going forward that's the news
uh yeah I mean you can believe that or
not I mean I don't think that's really
the key here
the key is the filings in court
I don't know if you remember the name
John Eastman
and the Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
attempt
and he's the the the architect of that
memo
the memo to overturn your Constitution
it was the memo that was being used to
try to convince Mike Pence to stall the
certification of volts votes so that
they could take it back to the States
was their phrasing what they meant was
is to submit fraudulent fraudulent
electors excuse me
it's [__] hump day
yes I'm just not uh
on top of it this morning they were
going to use the stall tactic
that John Eastman laid out in his memo
to throw it back to the states which
means
fraudulently
steal the electors submit their own
right a set of fake electors as we know
them that was the scheme of John Eastman
now as you remember John Eastman and
Donald Trump were in communication
and there was emails that were sent to
John Eastman
and he tried he tried his damnedest
to invoke attorney-client privilege
here's the thing there was a federal
judge out in California that told him uh
no this is not attorney client privilege
this is crime
this is fraud
and this Falls underneath the crime and
fraud
exclusion meaning you do not get to
invoke the attorney-client privilege to
hide crime
now when presented with the evidence of
these emails the judge laid out
perfectly exactly the crime that they
had committed
which was obstruction obstruction of a
official proceeding
here is the deal
there's a new X former once was attorney
never should have probably been an
attorney in the first place
that served for Trump at the altar of
the orange Mussolini Jesus
who believe the Cheeto dust q and honors
lie so much so that he's now probably
going to be
have criminal liability
he's being gonna be compelled to testify
to the grand jury
by Jack Smith under the crowd Jesus
Christ the crime fraud exclusion of the
attorney-client privilege
now this is really important this is
this is really [__] important people
and I know I know you naysayers out
there that hate marriage Garland you're
trying to protect shrimp and blah blah
blah yakety smackity I get it I know I
know there's just some [__] people on
the left
that don't have [__] common sense and
if you're one of them in the chat that
uh Tony you run triple trouble you're
never going to see a day in court he's
already seen the day in court
he was his company
his organization that he ran
his family organization
that has made him appear to be rich his
entire life was charged with 17 counts
of criminal fraud
okay
now I believe that the Manhattan D.A and
Fannie Willis down in Georgia
aren't going to make this move as fast
as Jack Smith
it seems that there could be indictments
in the Manhattan DA's office it seems
that there could be indictments I mean
vanny Willis has only said it's
inevitable
now I'm George
it feels like to me the Jack Smith
is coming to the table with all the
tools he needs to bury Trump underneath
the prison if a judge so allow it
now here's the timeline because I I want
you to understand how a federal case
works
and how slow it [__] moves
so Jack Smith is presenting his case to
a grand jury which is super important
folks in other words Jack Smith is
seeking indictments they're not just
collecting evidence they're presenting
the evidence to a grand jury to ignite
or not to indict depending on the grand
jury's opinion of the evidence
you understand that right
you get where the where it's at
so all you naysayers out there that act
like the Jack Smith isn't going to
amount to hella beans you're not
understanding what is happening this is
way different
way different than what the Mueller
situation was number one Donald Trump is
not the president of the United States
no matter what the Cuban honor say
he is not the president of the United
States
nor does he have the protections of the
president United States
under the presidential records act like
he claims
or he he and he tried to attempt to keep
while he was President so he's protected
it's all [__]
it's not real
and it's different from the Mueller case
in this case
they are seeking he is now seeking an
attorney to testify before a criminal
grand jury
about Donald Trump's obstruction
key word there if you remember what I
just said about Eastman
and how a federal judge already laid out
the criminal case for obstruction of
official proceeding
they are now going to use
the crime and fraud exclusion of that
attorney-client privilege to seek their
testimony I would almost bet
I would almost bet a guy who prosecutes
war war criminals I I mean just gonna go
out on a limb here
and say this guy's pretty good at
Prosecuting people
especially [__] boxes like Donald Trump
and anyone who would lie for him my
guess is that he's gonna go seek this
crime fraud exclusion for this attorney
this former Trump attorney and really
probably former attorney we should
probably just kind of foresee that and
so foreshadowing I would imagine any
attorney who works for Trump is bound to
lose their [__] law license
bound to lose it I mean you're just kind
of giving it away you almost might as
well just burn the [__] as you
decide to work for him the point is this
you think Jack Smith
with his entire career his entire
reputation on the line
is going to go to a federal judge and
seek this exclusion
without a shred of evidence
you're gonna be wrong you're gonna be
dead [__] wrong
you are not on the right side of the
facts here you are not on the right side
of logic and rational thinking you just
are not if you believe
that that Jack Smith knows that he's
going to get
this crime and fraud exclusion with with
almost pure certainty
I'm saying he probably feels that way
he probably has the evidence
to know that
so think about all and think about this
this attorney is attorney I don't know a
cockroach I think is his last name I
think this is this attorney's name
cockroach
I know it starts with a c and just you
know cockroach see it comes right out
we've never heard this name before
we haven't really heard this name many
times I mean yeah we hear about the the
um Christina Bob
the seditionist Rudy Giuliani
the Kraken
of course we've heard those names Turley
not totally excuse me
um trusty
trusty Turley oh give who gives a [__]
they're both stupid
we've heard these names but we have not
heard
this attorney's name many times it's
just not a well-known character in this
Saga
so my question to you naysayers out
there is this
what else do you think Jack Smith knows
that we have no [__] idea
and what else do you think Jack Smith
has the evidence on that we have no clue
exist
I mean up until a week ago well not even
less than a week ago we didn't even know
the laptop from hell was pure
unadulterated projection
that that there is a laptop that exists
that somehow got Donald Trump's stolen
classified document stolen from us his
documents that he stole from us onto the
laptop and possibly on a thumb drive
I mean I mean we can only assume that
prior to the reporting
how many laptops are there how many
thumb drives are there
how many emails are there
I'm I almost damn
guarantee you we are gonna find out that
Donald Trump or someone in his orbit
email classified information that he
stole from us
and it's on a private server
the email is stored on I'm not [__]
you
go ahead [__] doubt me [__] doubt
me you can do whatever you want whatever
stupid thing you want to say because
here's the timeline here's a timeline
that we're dealing with and I had
someone uh asked me this morning
if they think this will ruin his chance
of becoming the nominee I said oh hell
no
this only advances his March towards the
nomination
when Jack Smith indicts Donald Trump
it will only ensure that he gets the
nomination folks
and I'm not I'm not bullshitting you on
this the only thing that is going to
stop Donald Trump from getting
nominations if he chokes on a Big Mac
that's it
and the only reason why is because this
fool will do anything and everything
and say anything and Destroy anyone in
his path
to protect his own ass
and the only option he has here and he
knows it
and you can tell he knows it in his
desperation to become the president of
the United States again
his only option is to become the
president because here's the timeline
it seems as if Jack Smith is moving in
on indictments
very soon
he wouldn't be seeking the crime fraud
exclusion at this point I don't believe
to present before the grand jury
if he's not presenting outright crimes
to them
he's presenting his case for indictments
for crimes
he's seeking the crime fraud exclusion
Because he believes with evidence that
the attorney and Trump
we're committing crime and fraud okay
it's not it's not complicated and
understand these things
it's gonna take a few months for the
grand jury to get those indictments in
Jack Smith to align those indictments
and to present and now it's probably it
might take longer than that and the
reason why is because there's probably
so much [__] crime there's so much
[__] crime tied up in between the
January 6th where Donald Trump defrauded
his supporters to commit a coup
and then he stole our [__] top secret
and classified documents to cover up
that coup
and God knows how much crime Jack
Smith's gonna uncover when he starts
overturning those rocks
and God knows how many [__] people
are going to be involved in these crimes
how many hundreds of people are going to
be involved in these crimes
with trying to overturn our election
and then the cover-up and the
obstruction of the cover-up
are trying to overturn our election
I said I give you the timeline but one
more point I want to make here before
the timeline
because I want to explain the timeline
for you and the reason why I believe
Donald Trump is going to face off with
Joe Biden in the 2024 presidential
election
here is
here is uh something the history is
going to tell and you Trump supporters
out there
um I just want you to keep this in mind
as you continue to support him when he
gets indicted because they're going to
get even more
in their support for him I mean they're
going to be frothing at the mouth for
support
of this Criminal
so remember just remember this one point
as history tells the story in the next
20 30 40 50 years if you're still alive
by then I mean some of his supporters
aren't giving me live some of them will
be
just remember
Donald Trump is going to go down in
history
as the most corrupt
the worst the dumbest president that we
have ever had but more importantly
in the history books it is going to be
written that thousands
thousands of people
paid a price and went to prison
for him
and for him alone for his corruption his
fraud his delusion
thousands
are gonna go to prison and pay a price
for this buffoon
you're probably one of them you may not
go to prison you may not get in legal
trouble
but you're gonna pay a price there's
always a price of delusion
here's the timeline
promised you the timeline I've kind of
went over this before
um if Jack Smith doesn't die in the next
few months Donald Trump that is now I I
would guess again that there's going to
be several other indictments but the
most important one to the presidential
campaign into your democracy
is the indictment against Donald Trump
now what's going to happen is Donald
Trump's going to yell and scream you
can't indict me I'm running for
president I'm running for you can't
indict me I'm running for president
and a judge is not going to buy that
argument
because there's no debates there's no
primaries
you can't even file
to be on a ballot at this point
you can just announce
and theoretically run so more than
likely a federal judge is not going to
buy that argument now here's the
argument that they will buy and Trump is
counting on
this is why he's going to burn down
Nikki Haley this is why he's called
meatball Rhonda Santos
a pedophile
and and my guess is by the end of the
month
by the end of February because he's
definitely going to want to do it in
Black History Month with how to doubt
Donald Trump is going to want to do it
at the most disgusting time my guess is
by the end of this month he will say out
loud
that Nikki Haley is a bad Confederate
she's a horrible Confederate she would
have made a the worst confederate
soldier ever
she's got to say that [__] he is going
to say that [__]
I mean maybe not so many words I'm gonna
try to get him to [__] say it
that's what I want that's the Civil War
that I want
but he is signaling that he is willing
to do anything
to win this nomination absolutely
anything and Destroy anyone he does not
give a [__] because there's only one way
out of this
and in the run-up
to the 2024 general election we have to
keep in mind we have to remember we are
now in the Republican primary cycle that
is what we're in they are all vying for
the Republican nomination that is the
only election that is ongoing right now
and I think that Joe Biden should put
off announcing that he's going to run
until well until the summer let these
[__] idiots fight oh hell yeah Let
Them Fight let Donald Trump destroy
every single one of these son of a
[__] and watch Ron desantos stand
back and be a meatball
and not enter the race because he's
terrified clearly of trump
and more importantly he's terrified of
his support
just like any other Republican
I mean Mitch McConnell came out in front
of a microphone yesterday and basically
said well yeah admit for him hell yeah
vote for him
the reason why Republican after
Republican National Republican is
getting in front of a microphone is
because of the timeline
even if Donald Trump is indicted he can
still run for president and we should
let him
we should let him lose
even under criminal indictment Donald
Trump can still run for president all
the Republicans know that every [__]
one of Mitch McConnell sununu Ron
desantos
and [__] meatball
Nikki Haley they understand this
him being under indictment is not going
to stop him from running frankly it's
his protection from trial
this is very key in the timeline the
trial is the most important thing
indictment's gonna lift his profile with
the [__] moglodytes
you don't think his support is gonna get
even more amped up
now that the government is weaponized
against Trump it's all a conspiracy q
and on I mean of course they are
Q Anon is a hell of a drug folks and
it's just a q Anon World we're living in
it they are totally going to invent this
idea
that he's gonna take on the
weaponization of the government that is
against him and the reason why is
because they want to tear down our
government our democracy
don't you see don't you see the future
developing in front of your eyes
in our body politic
it's so simple to see of how he's going
to take advantage of his supporters In
This Moment he's going to take advantage
of what we see as a death blow to an to
any presidential candidate he's going to
take advantage of it like he always does
and he always [__] he always
always
institutes fraud and lies
as his foundation
of his entire existence
and no one else is going to come within
a hundred [__] miles of that
nomination because of it because when we
get down to the primaries and he wins
primary after primary after primary
after primary he's going to look at a
federal judge and the federal judge is
probably going to have no choice
but to put the trial of Donald Trump off
after the 2024 election
he's going to be the nominee
you really at that point and this is his
plan folks this is his plan
this is the entire plan yeah if you're
if you're you're unaware he is
predictably unpredictable
a federal judge is going to Grant him
his wish
and kick the trial of Donald Trump past
the 2024 election
to give him a chance to run his
president because he is technically the
nominee
when he wins primary after primary after
primary after primary and if you doubt
that he's going to win primaries
he just [__] doubt me okay just just
[__] I mean barring again him choking on
a goddamn bit Mac which I'm not saying
that the world wouldn't be better if he
would eat 20 20 buckets of chicken a day
I'm not saying I'm just fried chicken by
the way not Grill we definitely want it
to be deep fried and extra crispy
hopefully he he chokes on a bone just
saying
you don't think the Republicans are
hoping for this too
I mean Jesus Christ they have to get in
front of microphone be like uh yeah so
uh I don't want Donald Trump be
president and I think it'll destroy a
party but if he if he's the nominee I'll
vote for him what the [__] out here with
that nonsense
if get the [__] out of here
the 2024 election
is gonna be a Simple Choice
we have to make it that choice
and that's where we're at
and if you don't realize
that where we're headed is that position
that we are going to have an entire
political party that is going to back
someone who is federally [__]
indicted for obstruction
of Justice and that candidate is going
to catapult himself to be the nominee of
that same party
because he's claiming falsely that the
government is weaponized against him
don't you see it just go listen to Jim
Jordan for a half a second and
understand that Jim Jordan is talking to
Donald Trump every [__] day
this is going to be the rhetoric this is
going to be how he keeps the nomination
and who else is going to get it at this
point it's him and Nikki Haley you think
Nikki Haley's gonna win [__] out of here
with that nonsense
Nikki Haley can't even decide what side
of the Confederacy she's on
and that's the fight we're in folks
that's the fight we're in
there's a lot of things to talk about
today a lot
a lot
but for you who care about our democracy
this Jack Smith story is one of the most
important one of the most important to
to our long-term democracy
because as much as it's going to
give the moglodytes The energy they need
to justify their [__] lies about
weaponization of the government to make
him the nominee
it should engage you too
it should engage all of America
can you imagine the opportunity that
you're going to have over the next
18 months
to convince people around you of what is
really going on
you think the Republicans are going to
hide this you don't think they're going
to say this out loud in public
folks it's going to be on display for
the entire world to see
and we must not let our country dilute
itself
as we fight about who's deregulating
trains and who's against labor unions
give me a [__] break there is no
there is no debate and no question on
what happened in Ohio and what is
happening with the derailment of trains
and anyone who says any different is not
[__] paying attention and hasn't been
paying attention for the last goddamn 40
years
40 years yes this didn't just happen in
the last six months our last six years
you don't you don't think the railroads
are run by human beings
how do you think it you know you think
we're gonna run rail cars in the
railroads and trains off AI get the [__]
out of here with that nonsense
it's ridiculous
and you're going to be distracted by
Republicans yelling and screaming about
small government [__] that [__]
let's get real on what really matters
today and what is going to matter in the
future we cannot keep our Eye Off the
Ball
we cannot keep it off the ball
and yes we must we must
we must solve these issues in the
meantime but we can't keep our eye off
the ball that is why you come here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch make sure to
hit that subscribe button if you're here
oh my gosh you should see these these
new uh surfs that [__] shirts
are flying off the shelves go to store
not D Tony michaels.com that's store dot
the tonymichaels.com who get your Surfs
Up [__] merch not only do we
have a shirt we now have a coffee mug
that's right everybody there is a coffee
mug on there and I I promise someone was
asking this morning on the patreon page
they asked if we were going to have a
PAB 45 the [__] ass [__] we're gonna
have a couple of those designs
we got a couple designs in the works for
the [__] ass [__] 45 PAB 45 I promise
you they are coming but go check out at
store.d Tony michaels.com check out the
Surf's Up merchandise I I'll probably
this afternoon I'll put up a sticker and
maybe uh maybe a long sleeve shirt since
it's not winter anymore do you guys want
a hoodie since it's not I didn't I
didn't think he'd want a hoodie because
it's not winter anymore but I guess
maybe maybe like I mean it is winter but
we're going in the spring is what I mean
the weather is going to get warmer
I don't know by the time you buy it and
get it hell it might be spring already
so if you want a hoodie just let the
chat know uh we'll we'll put a hoodie up
as well with the Surf's Up [__]
on it so go check that out and we'll
we're gonna have another Surf's Up so
we'll have two Surfs Up
um designs and then we'll have two
[__] ass [__] 45 designs so
um stay tuned you're not going to want
to go anywhere so you see at least see
the designs of this merch but everyone
stick around because I've got a lot of
Clips to show you today we got a lot of
news to get through including a trained
derailment and Ted Cruz another train
derailment stick around we'll be right
back right after this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment we're
[Music]
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
okay okay so I I totally underestimated
the need for hoodies
I [__] up royally
a lot of people like the zip up hoodies
the um the hoodies that we had for the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people the Liberty hoodies here I'll
show you I'll show you the Liberty
hoodies
here is the Liberty hoodie but this
one's a zip up you see that see how it's
a zip up
so maybe I'll I'll do a zip up Surf's Up
hoodie and a just a pullover hoodie as
well for all of you since I totally
underestimated we have a lot of
listeners in Canada and up north
some people in the UK and they're saying
look we were hoodies are a year-round
deal okay and I totally underestimated I
apologize
when I'm wrong I'll admit I'm wrong I
was wrong about hoodies I will not be
wrong about Jack Smith
doubt me you [__] go ahead go ahead you
[__] doubt me whatever you want to do
whatever you want to do go ahead and
also doubt me on that Trump's gonna be
their nominee
I did this person that called me this
morning that was asking these questions
they're like I don't know I just I just
don't know if you're right I'm like I
you can think I'm wrong that's fine
I I it doesn't matter even if I am wrong
think about this even if I am wrong and
let's say Nikki Haley wins the
nomination oh that's that's really [__]
that's really tough to say there's no
[__] way I I had someone actually
suggest this morning too that Nikki
Haley is is making a bid for the vice
presidential uh ticket that's the
dumbest [__] thing ever if if Nikki
Haley and her team listen to me listen
to me very closely if Nikki Haley and
her team are seeking the vice
presidential nomination she would be on
television in any Trader News Network
that she could to be talking about how
the election was stolen in 2020 and her
the election was stolen from her
and she would not be running against him
she would be doing Cheeto dust fellatio
on any Trader TV News Network that would
let her deny any election that she
wanted
where Republicans lost you get me it's
Carrie Lake Carrie lake is going to be
the Vice Presidential nominee
if if
Nikki Haley's idea to run for president
at this point against Donald Trump is to
be the Vice Presidential nominee that is
not out that's not how Trump works at
all
that's not how he works at all
it's not even close to how it works he's
going to destroy Nikki Haley and well
technically he already has
but what we should what we should be
doing
in this space again we talked about it
yesterday with pod Saves America and
several others and I don't want to point
fingers and name names because I may
make people feel really uncomfortable
but our narratives should not be that
Nikki Haley is the worst hypocrite ever
in the history ever and she should never
be the president she's not going to be
the nominee
Nikki Haley in our effort
pro-democracy people's effort right in
our political effort because again I
keep I have to say this time and time
again there are two things that are
involved in politics
there is policy and that's the the art
of government and there's elections and
that's the art of politics okay you have
to politicize every [__] thing
and it is so important that you look
through a certain lens when you're
politicizing something it is it is it is
the most important thing that you can do
in politics
you cannot just willy-nilly act like
Nikki Haley can't oh we shouldn't elect
Nikki Haley as president that's not even
the election we're in you [__]
boneheads we are not in a presidential
election we are in the Republican
primary you have to look at it and
politicize it through that scope
that is the most important thing
we have to get him to fight each other
let Donald Trump distort destroy Nikki
Haley because in all reality
in all reality let's say we were in a
different [__] timeline a completely
different [__] timeline an alternate
universe
where Donald Trump didn't even exist
with the power that he has
with the real America verse Nazi party
imagine who would be
the up and coming in that reality not in
the what not in the actual reality we
live in we always want to generate these
alternate realities even though why do
why do we want to do what they do is
generate an alternate reality where
we'll just be [__] upset
and have our asses handed to us why do
we do this to ourselves
the alternate reality is is that the
governor
Nikki Haley of South Carolina
who stripped away the Confederate Banner
off the capitol grounds
because she is not for the Confederacy
think about think about if we were in
that timeline we are not in that
timeline stop acting like we are in that
timeline so stop telling liberals why
Nikki Haley is the better choice than
Donald Trump
that's what you're doing
yeah she's a hypocrite but what
Republican isn't
what you have to do is use that issue
of the Confederate flag to get Donald
Trump to attack her
and it not only shows
that Donald Trump is a pile of garbage
because he will be their nominee
but it gives him an opportunity to
attack her
and the other thing it gives the
opportunity
for his base to do
is to show their true colors
this is very important that we know the
tail that is wagging the dog it is very
important I [__] pointed out every
day here on the Tony Michaels podcast
how do you think we we fended off a red
wave in 2022. how do you think we did it
do you think it was just happen stance
no we pointed it out every single day
and we built a coalition around
democracy
do you think the Confederacy do you
think the Confederacy is democracy
do you think that's a Beacon of Hope for
democracy in this country do you
there is nothing more than I would love
than Donald Trump be be hailing the
Confederate oh I love the Confederacy
and Nikki Haley she's a bad Confederate
it's what we need that's what we need
that is the position that us as the pro
democracy Coalition need to put
ourselves in and yeah am I saying the
quiet part out loud you goddamn right I
am
you goddamn right I am
the reason why is because we must
protect our constitution
and he has said that he wants to tear it
up and wipe his ass with it
as long as as long as getting rid of the
Constitution makes him the dictator and
King of the United States of Maga
that's what he wants
and we must push back against it same
way as we talked about the other day and
I've been talking about this for weeks
and weeks and weeks but Texas Paul
brought it up yesterday
we have to Democrats in blue States
have to gerrymander the [__] out of
their districts
we that that's what we have to do
and you're like oh Tony oh my God we
can't be them oh man we can't stoop to
their [__] we cannot
the only way to get them in Texas Paul
said it yesterday too the only way to
get them to agree
to stop doing this [__]
is to prove that we can do it too and we
can use it against them as soon as they
know that liberalism has picked up their
methods as weaponization on them
politically oh baby will they change
their [__] minds just look at what's
happening with the trains and the
railroads
they're all for big government this week
oh my God they want people to judge to
be the dictator of the trains
why isn't the federal government
regulating braking systems
why why why Joe Biden why aren't you
doing that
it's because the Trump Administration
deregulated the braking systems not only
that they banging up the unions who do
you think runs a [__] trains
besides workers
and if you think if you think that
blaming
the trained derailments on Pete
butterjudge
or the Biden Administration isn't
[__] bone-headed
and you're a [__] bonehead
and to act like Joe Biden
and this in this in this world that we
live in right now is not the most
pro-union president that we've seen in
our lifetimes you are a dumb
[__] you have not been listening
you've not been paying attention
but we do not live in an autocracy folks
we don't do you want to
you do not just get to wave a [__]
magic wand
this is why it is so important that you
engage in your democracy when you don't
you have [__] cowards
and liars and cheats and frauds who own
and control half of our legislator
listen this this regulation on this
breaking machine
and and to be frank the labor union it
requires appropriation of funds
there is only one part of our federal
government that is in charge of
appropriating funds I don't know if you
know who they are
maybe maybe before you go vote in 2024
maybe you should [__] figure that out
the group of people who appropriate
funds
for National Transportation projects
like the railroads and the braking
systems and unions and workers
is the House of Representatives
you think Kevin McCarthy Kevin McCarthy
can't even bring a security a border
security Bill to the floor because he
can't get the [__] votes out of his
caucus they are [__] worthless
he is worthless the only Bill they can
get [__] enough votes on is bills
that are just outright lies
like how they they fired 87 000 IRS
agents get the [__] out of here you did
not fire 87 000 IRS agents you didn't do
[__]
you sold your lied to your constituency
you wrote a bill based on a [__] line
you voted based on a lie
you think you think Kevin McCarthy and
the Republican caucus have the backbone
and the courage to bring a bill to
regulate
the railroad industry
oh here's some funny [__] oh
you're some funny [__]
you're some funny [__] and of
course of course this the the uh
the horrifying event in Ohio
where chemicals have sport out poured
out and destroyed an entire Community do
you want to know whose fault that is do
you know what do you want you're not
going to want to hear this this is real
You're Gonna Go Tony you sick son of a
[__] you oh my God I can't even believe
you'd say that do you know whose fault
that is in Ohio
you want to know the people of Ohio
yeah that that's that's who is at fault
here
the people in Ohio who are voting
you got to remember who Ohio is folks
Ohio is a rust-built state
Ohio is one of the backbone states of
manufacturing in this country
and I don't know if you know this
but one of the backbones of
manufacturing in this country
is far to make sure
that our labor is paid for appropriately
is the Union
do you know who won Ohio in 2016
do you know who won Ohio in 2020
do you know who won Ohio in 2022 as
United States Senator do you know who is
the governor of Ohio
folks we should not stand around blaming
just the politicians we elect these
[__] We the People it's our
government we did this
and tell the people of Ohio wake up and
stop [__] voting in these these
[__] scummy ass Republicans who have
no [__] courage to stand up against
Corporate America no [__] courage to
stand up against capital in this country
and support the [__] worker
even though even though Ohio is a Rust
Belt state
it's a labor state
supposed to be it's not anymore
because they voted in people because of
abortion
and God Guns
the derailment folks let me tell let me
let me explain this again the derailment
in Ohio
and the chemical problem the chemicals
that leaked out and the problems that
they're having right now in Ohio is the
fault of the people and the voters and
the people who didn't vote in Ohio
do you have any idea what the election
in 2016 would look like
if Ohio would have went to Hillary
Clinton do you have any idea
do you know do you know what it would
look like
do you have any idea what the makeup of
our Senate would be today
if JD Vance would have been kicked to
the curb do you have any idea any idea
what would be happening right now on the
ground if there was a person who gave a
[__] about the Ohioans and the American
people in that in that [__] town
if there was a Democrat as the governor
they would declare a national emergency
and Joe Biden and FEMA and EPA would do
every single bit of every single
resource that they could to help that
[__] community and dewine has turned
away the [__] federal government
he said as much in a [__] press
conference he I'll show you the [__]
clip if you need to see it Governor
dewine said I talked to the president he
said he would do anything and everything
to help us with this with this situation
and I told him to go get [__] and I'm
not going to call him back
the people of Ohio did this
you have to you have to stop blaming
someone else
in Tennessee in Tennessee yesterday in
Tennessee I don't know if you noticed
this but in Tennessee yesterday they
made it illegal to dress up as a woman
it's a felony now and they didn't even
go through the proper legislative
channels
unconstitutionally put this law into
effect where it's a felony for you to
put on a [__] dress
because they're terrified they're
terrified of other people's genitalia
do you know whose fault that is
that's the people of Tennessee's fault
we got we got we gotta stop blaming we
gotta stop blaming other [__]
we have to start [__] realizing that
this is our government and we are doing
these things to ourselves
stop being so [__] weak we're
liberals we're strong there is strength
and freedom
that chemical disaster that derailment
of the train in Ohio and the cleanup and
the effort and all the people who are
going to get [__] sick who are
probably gonna design die because of
this who are going to have their
property destroyed their lives upended
it is the people of Ohio's fault
doubt me
that's right
you don't like to hear it you don't want
to hear it I understand it sounds oh my
God Tony you're just Jesus Christ you're
going way off a limb here
2016 2020 2022.
dewine's the governor JD Vance is the
[__] Senator JD Vance is spreading
lies that Joe Biden's doing nothing and
dewine told Biden to get [__] I don't
want your [__] help
because if I have your help our
corporations will end up having to pay
all kinds of [__] money
and I just can't have that I can't have
Capital [__] be responsible for their
disasters in this country and I know a
lot of people want to blame it on
corporations want to bring it on
capitalism I get it I understand
but there's only one entity that stands
in the way of capital taking advantage
of the American people and it's us
us the government us we the
[__] people
so we must look inward
when we go into this election cycle it
is more important now than ever that we
self-evaluate
and make others self-evaluate themselves
it is super important for the the people
of Ohio to understand the mistakes that
they made the people of Tennessee to
understand the mistakes that they've
made with this anti-trans bill it's a
[__] hate bill
to understand the consequences and the
mistakes that we made when we elect the
Republicans and [__] Mississippi with
Dobbs to overturn Roe v Wade
we did that
you say oh they gerrymandered they
cheated so we should do it back
you want to take your democracy you want
to defend your democracy defend it
use politics politicize someone accused
me the other day of politicizing
the shooting at MSU you goddamn right I
will
every [__] mass shooting I will
politicize the [__] out of it
and I won't stop either I don't give a
[__] not one
I will politicize anything and
everything I [__] have to to promote
democracy
it is on the ropes
but we can win
because liberalism is strength and I
know there's someone who agrees with me
not maybe on every point that I just
made I'm not I'm not going to put words
in his mouth but Gabe Sanchez uh I'm
sure there's some of that that you uh
yeah yeah I can I can uh I can relate to
that fight and fire in you oh yeah I
mean here's the thing when I found so
that night for for instance like I have
my own personal story for MSU shooting
and I was just there
on the campus I was there I was on
campus in June uh a friend can you can
you describe because I think that's one
thing that that of that story that is
kind of being sideboard because a lot of
people don't understand
what the campus is like there because
the campus is [__] is sprawling it's
huge right yeah it is it it spreads wide
and far there's a main road just like
um you know I would say University of
Illinois or or Marquette or other places
like there's a main road like an artery
that goes in and out yeah that goes in
and out right in case you all the way uh
into downtown and it takes you all the
way out to the stakes right like it'll
run through
but you've got the stadium right there
you've got the buildings you got the the
dorm rooms you've got uh the downtown
kind of like student not Student Union
but like it's the it's where you go if
you're like you know go get it that's
where the population of the school lives
right right and so right there there's a
hotel
and uh I went this summer because a
buddy who lives in East Lansing right
he's got family in in his in East
Lansing he's got family who went to East
Lansing uh he has ties to the community
so naturally he and his wife
that's where they met they went to
school there uh in high school
and so they decided that they wanted to
get married there so all of us College
friends all came from all over the
country came in for that weekend
and the campus and it was the summer too
but it was crazy and here and you want
to know what else was really important
that same day
was when uh
uh Roe v Wade was overturned
so that same day that you were on that's
why I couldn't jump on with you on that
stream is because I was literally at a
wedding reception
but the day that that happened there
were already people on campus that were
being you know that had their signs and
said you you think guns have more rights
than my body right you think I posted
one the other day it said if if you can
ignore if you you can ignore abortions
if you can abort avoid school shootings
exactly and so I had I was literally
hanging out with with my friends before
the wedding and we're in like kind of
the pool room and you know we had some
beer and we were just drinking and
meanwhile I look out of the window and
hours earlier the decision was made Roe
v Wade was being overturned right and I
was like ah [__] man there's a [__]
Cloud over my day already
so we get in we're all hanging out and
I'm looking out over onto the main
street of the campus where it's the
downtown area of where all the students
hang out the restaurants and the bars
and everything
and ICN one one corner there's there's
uh two guys and and I think three girls
and they've got a sign up that basically
says like I should have equal rights if
you think a gun has more rights than me
then you're [__] up basically is what
the message said and then the other side
it was this woman who was very you know
pro-christian and then was coming at all
of these people who are who are
protesting right honk if you believe
that I should have equal rights honk if
you believe that I should have bodily
autonomy and this woman had to put her
face into their business right put
herself into their business and say oh
well you shouldn't think this way and
that's not how it actually is and it's
really protecting you and all this
[__]
so anyway I was there on campus one that
happened so that was one thing
and I've got friends who live I've got
other friends who've gone to MSU I've
got friends who live right outside East
Lansing and I've got my friends parents
who also live right outside like right
there on the cusp of the University
so when the shootings were announced I
texted my buddy he didn't respond to me
I figured oh maybe he's asleep because
it's three hours ahead there in Michigan
maybe he's you know safe and sound in
his house and he's sleeping and you know
luckily I got a text three three o'clock
my time and he was like hey we were
watching up late you know everyone was
kind of on edge and it's really crazy to
have something that's so close to home
right both
emotionally and physically right you're
literally close to campus and also you
have so many ties to campus
and then I've got another friend her
cousin goes to MSU right all of these
people have have the six degrees the way
that she said it you know she had
multiple ties to
[Music]
um
to uh the shooting at MSU the the the
pulse club shooting
um she had multiple other ones she's
like I'm tired of playing this game of
Six Degrees of murder
I'm tired of playing this game I'm tired
of being someone who is attached to
someone else who's attached to someone
else
that has died
you know uh last night yesterday I
watched two videos of people who were
saying I'm a student who was in this
previous school shooting in high school
and now I've had to sit through that in
college right and I know there's at
least there's a one video that you're
about to show yeah
this is even this is even Wilder to
dream of yesterday because I brought up
the student the students that were
saying we were we were in the goddamn
Oxford's high school shooting right so
that's the second one which Oxford is
like about 25 30 minutes away from
Lansing from what I understand there's
the Oxford one right I was just reading
about a girl who the mother was sharing
the story and be like my child was in
the Oxford school shooting in 2021 and
now was in the MSU shooting in 2023 and
then there's the video of the girl yeah
this one this this right this video is
wild like if if well go ahead
I was just gonna say like it was surreal
to think back like you know I was just
there you know half a year ago or eight
months ago or whatever
having a good time wedding and then not
only am I there on campus but then I
also experienced this moment Roe v Wade
is overturned and so I've got college
students who are there over the summer
who are protesting on the corner right
and then I find out just the other night
that the school shooting happened so I'm
like holy [__] you know I'm texting out
to friends who live nearby I'm texting
my buddy who literally lives in East
Lansing just got a house there just like
not even four months ago there with his
wife
and texting them to be like are you guys
okay just want to make sure you're safe
like I don't know what the [__] going
on I'm just reading about what's going
on and luckily everyone that I know is
safe but I mean like it's just one of
those things that it it is insane to
think about how close we really are to
these events they happen so frequently
and so little time between each one that
now we are bound to live in a world
where you're going to experience either
firsthand or second hand through someone
you know a shooting a mass shooting a
grocery store shooting a school shooting
I mean thankfully the the Buffalo
[__] Mass shooter got life in prison
for shooting 10 African-American people
in that that grocery store
but still like the fact that we have to
live every other day where it's not just
you know if it's not in the news I
guarantee you there's another shooting
that you can track that was in a small
town and if it's not that then it's a
bigger shooting and it's not that then
it's an even bigger shooting or if it's
a you know this or this or that I mean
like you know we had the shooting that
was here in La that was just a mile a
mile and a half away from my house
right and it's not just a white guy it
could be anyone but the idea that
people can just easily access guns and
then take out whatever emotional
frustration or stress or anxiety or pain
or whatever they have I went on anyone
else because they're [__] pissed or
they have some you know uh mental health
problem or whatever it might be the
accessibility to the guns is [__]
insane
and that's the reason why the frequency
between these shootings is just ever
it's just [__] accelerating like in
math this would you you would look at a
chart and be like oh that like it's a
[__] hockey stick right like oh my
God it's not something when you're like
oh you know in business hockey stick
growth is great hockey stick growth in
this [__] mass shooting Market it's
not something you want to [__] be
advocates for and when you've got people
on the house floor and people in the
senate or whatever that are wearing
[__] AR-15 lapel pins [__] that [__]
okay I want to address something here
before I play this video because and I
don't know what your intention is about
this [__] I went over this yesterday
okay and if you if you if you have a if
you need if you need to go back and
maybe it was Monday [__] I don't know
these days run together to me all the
rants they literally run together me
that's why that's why a number of the
episodes I keep track but I I'm dead
serious because I'm like which one was
that but now there's like 350
000 so I don't even know which one we're
on here's the thing Moe I went over this
yesterday and before I show this clip I
think this is actually important to go
over
it's that liberals do on guns they do
own guns liberals own yens for way
different reasons than what two a Bros
own guns I told you yesterday I grew up
on a farm yes I'm a farm boy I grew up
on a [__] Farm the closest
neighbor we had to us on the on the farm
that I lived was about a quarter mile
away you could see him from the house
you couldn't hear him you couldn't even
shoot him from the house really with our
guns they weren't they weren't that
powerful they just weren't
hey Moe when I was a kid when we had
guns in the house
we didn't lock our doors
like when we would go on vacation Gabe
we didn't lock our doors because I don't
think we had a [__] key that's how
often we were worried about people
breaking into our house and protecting
ourselves our our equipment our cars
we're all sitting in the driveway and
out you know outside
unlocked with the keys in it the garage
door was always open it never [__]
closed I mean this idea that that we
have guns for protecting ourselves is
really [__] dumb now I was talking to
someone who grew up in Kentucky
and I didn't mention this the other day
but I I talked to someone who's exactly
and I was talking to him about this
issue and they said well you know when I
was young the neighbor across the road
he's an old man and he had a gun and if
someone pulled up his driveway that he
didn't know he would go out come outside
with a gun
you know and I said well I don't know
your neighbor I don't know the situation
but I almost bet you a thousand dollars
that it was a double barrel shotgun and
he's like holy [__] how did you know
that I'm like because his intent and I
said I almost bet another thousand
dollars that he had bird shot not
Buckshot in that gun if he had any shot
at all in that gun I said the only
intention
was to make sure that an honest person
stays honest when we were kids we had a
chain around a gate or a candle pasture
we rented a farm uh far away not far
away but down down the way right um
where we where we fed beef and we we
repaired some fence anyway the point is
is that we had a gate because we weren't
Daryl dime and there was a chain around
it and a padlock we never locked the
padlock we were just that that the
padlock hold the held the chain and my
dad would always say it's to keep an
honest person honest he's like really
honestly if someone wants to get in here
are going to get in here whether I lock
this goddamn padlock or not it's like
why some people in cities will be like
look I won't even lock my door just
don't break my window okay like put a
sign like look there's nothing you can
feel free to go through here whatever
you want I'll leave you [__] cookies
right right don't break my window all
right just don't damage my [__]
property yeah
but liberals do own guns
but liberals in general
have an idea of and we can go back to
the trains again if you want of
Regulation we have an idea of common
sense of what it means to own guns the
responsibility on guns and what it means
to have the responsibility to our
citizens to own guns so I just want to
point that out now this video here
um it's actually really chilling
um because I heard the stories of the
students who were in Oxford who
experienced the mass shooting and then
less than a year later they're at MSU
which is about 30 miles away
um and experienced mass shooting but
this one is way more chilling and I'm
not even gonna give you the the reason
why I want you to hear it from her voice
so
um I forget what her name is but let's
go and play this so the reason I'm
making this video right now is because
it is almost 1am and I am currently
directly across the street from where
the shootings at Michigan State occurred
I am 21 years old and this is the second
mass shooting that I have now lived
through
10 years and two months ago I survived
the Sandy Hook shooting and when I was
crouched in the corner in School in
Newtown Connecticut on 12 14 12. I was
hunched in the corner with my classmates
for so long that I actually got a PTSD
fracture in my L4 and L5 and my right
lower back
I now have a full-blown PTSD fracture
that flares up anytime I am in a
stressful situation or anything occurs
that's aggressive like that
the fact that this is the second mass
shooting that I have now lived through
is incomprehensible
my heart goes out to all the families
and the friends of the victims of this
Michigan State shooting
but we can no longer just provide love
and prayers it needs to be legislation
it needs to be action it's not okay
we can no longer allow this to happen we
can no longer be complacent
I'll forever be Sandy Hook strong and
forever be Spartan strong
now obviously um it's very shocking to
even comprehend that this young person
as a child not not a a teenager or a
young adult as a little child
went through one of the most horrific
mass shootings at an elementary school
that's happened in this country
um at Newtown Connecticut
and now at another school on a campus
has had to experience the same trauma
now I said the other day
you two a Bros Mo you liberals with guns
if you want to have the ability
to own guns in this country in the next
30 40 years
you better start listening to this
generation because President Biden's not
going to take your [__] guns Obama
didn't take your [__] guns if whoever
the Democrat the next Democratic
president is they're not going to take
your [__] guns the House of
Representatives not going to take your
[__] guns ascendant ain't gonna take
your guns I'll tell you who's gonna take
your [__] guns and if you aren't
listening you better open your
[__] ears
it's going to be this Young Generation
because they are not going to put their
children through what you put them
through you did again I know it's kind
of harsh and I know I know it's a
[__] of the truth
but we did this to these children we are
doing this we
by not standing up and saying in one
foul [__] and one voice you cannot do
this to us anymore we will not allow you
to do this to us anymore so a handful of
families
who own gun manufacturers can profit off
the blood of our citizens and our
children and I I seriously doubt I
seriously don't and you can doubt me but
I seriously doubt that this generation
coming up
because when we were kids Gabe I I I
said this the other day when I was in
elementary school in middle school and
high school and even in college I never
did an active shooter drill not one not
[__] one not one we did we did
tornado drills we did fire drills we did
earthquake drills we did all kinds of
drills we never did a mass shooter drill
because it was never a fear for Our
Generation this generation does more
goddamn Mass shooter drills and has more
protocol for Mass shooter drills than a
goddamn fire
and that's not to say like during our
time in school like they were obviously
I mean like obviously the one like you
go all the way back and like columbine
is the one that everyone remembers in
our in our generation of when it all
started right
and I think the closest thing was maybe
like a bomb threat was maybe something
that we did but like everything else
yeah was fire tornado earthquake it was
every like everyone go sit along the
sides of the columns go down to the
basement go here go there we're gonna
you know
get outside we're gonna make sure that
everyone is tallied all this stuff but
never did we never did we ever
could have imagined
that it would have gotten so bad there
would have been such an exponential
growth of mass shootings in this country
because of a lack of mental health care
and accessibility to guns and the and
the 2A Bros that decided that they
needed a gun just because they wanted to
[__] jerk off to it right
it's a weird [__] fetish that
Republicans have for guns we've seen it
we know it they [__] said it right
Lauren bobert says she has guns in her
bedroom which is the opposite place of
where you would ever want to have a
[__] gov and I'm pretty sure she
doesn't have as safe as what she said on
record it's a weird [__] fetish it is
[__] bizarre but to live now in a
Time
where you have to fear right and we've
said this before on the show and every
single other mass shooting that has
happened right
you could no longer go to the grocery
store you can no longer go to a
synagogue you can no longer go to your
church you can no longer go to your rec
center you can no longer go to your
school you can no longer go to your home
right none of these places in which you
originally thought were safe where you
could be with your friends and your
family or even in the protection of
those who are the law enforcement
because again we've also learned that
law enforcement aren't actually legally
obligated to protect you right we've
known that to be true it's literally in
the writing and we've seen it again and
again even on even on tape right we saw
it at Uvalde they [__] 400 Law
Enforcement Officers stood by holding
parents back who are willing to
sacrifice themselves to go save children
meanwhile other law enforcement who had
children in the school were going in and
getting children or other law
enforcement were sitting outside the
classroom letting the shooter [__]
just just ravaged through children
and again never could I have imagined
that we would live through a Time
where every every week every day every
month like whatever the [__]
frequency you want to look at it like
that we now have to say [__] there is
another shooting right and it
unfortunately is that cycle where you
know you've seen the graphics online
where somebody says oh there's a
shooting somebody says oh thoughts and
prayers somebody says this you know our
legislation our lawmakers of America
don't do [__] even though one party
wants to advocate for changes obviously
there's one party that doesn't which is
Republicans
and then the cycle continues right or we
find out that legislation was passed on
a local level to make guns even more
accessible after right Nikki Haley had a
[__] ad that was talking about gun
rights and making guns more accessible
you know Ron DeSantis in Florida last
month or earlier this month made guns
even more accessible by [__] open
carry who who needs who needs any kind
of permit to carry a gun well Missouri
Missouri is trying to make it to where
six-year-olds can walk around on the
street with AR-15s it doesn't I mean
even and even if you go back to like I
don't I don't know if people watched
Sasha bear Cohen's show that he had on
Showtime where he would you know get
into something
not Borat but a different character
right a different character where he
would you know he would play The Long
con right he would he would con these
Republican Representatives or other
people into having these interviews with
him uh it's pretty easy to do yeah yeah
it's pretty easy one of the people
specifically talked about like he you
know I think the character that he was
he was an Israeli uh Israeli military I
think or might have been one of the
people but I know that one of them
he talked with this Republican and who
was in power in some local level and he
was talking about
kindergartners having access to guns and
if you give them a gun then you'll be
able to rent these problems and the
person the Republican on the other one
was like yeah that sounds like a great
idea we should totally do that yeah
so [__] asinine what what they what
they fail to realize in this case is um
like the shooter in Uvalde he was a
former student there right
um the the kid at Newtown it was a it
was a kid uh who went in the uh the uh
Parkland shooting it was a student of
that high school so this idea that oh
well let's just give all the yeah that's
a really that's a really swell idea yeah
I mean just the kid the six-year-old
that brought the gun into school the
other day right last month I think where
he shot shot the teacher brilliant
brilliant work by the way yeah I think
that was in Virginia brilliant work
young brilliant yeah brilliant work and
you know what's funny even after that
Missouri's like hell that's a good idea
right
because they're all trying to out
Florida Florida they're all trying to
out Texas Texas right I mean this is
It's the lowest common denominator
because again all they say is thoughts
and prayers when Americans die at the
blood of their hands because I said to
this uh because uh Joshua had this tweet
of the the uh the student there from
yeah yeah uh from Michigan State who uh
was in these uh survivor of the Sandy
Hook shooting
um he said oh my God a survivor of the
2012 Sandy Hook Elementary shooting is
currently a student at Michigan State
and we don't put those numbers in our
head right because we forget how long
ago yeah that Sandy Hook was and we
didn't [__] nothing nothing we did
nothing and we forget how long ago was I
mean I still I still see video ads and
maybe it's because you know shootings
happen every day now but I still see
video ads on YouTube that are for the
Sandy Hook fund
here's the reality of it here's the
reality of it
in 10 years
10 years from now 12 years from now
we are going to have another video like
this where it is going to be a survivor
of Uvalde and they're going to be
telling a story about how they were in
the shooting in Uvalde and now they're
in a shooting at their University that
they're in it's the second time they've
been a victim and a survivor of a mass
shooting I wouldn't be surprised if that
person who's speaking as a Uvalde if a
former Uvaldi student is more than two
right like unless something changes the
like literally the math would indicate
that based on the frequency of shootings
and also in these states where
accessibility to guns is is available
for them because they're likely to go to
a university in Texas right
so you know it's one of those things
that 10 12 years down the line I
wouldn't be surprised if that kid is
like I've now lived through three mass
shootings one I was [__] shopping
with my parents another one I was a
little kid at a school and now I'm an
adult of attempting to be my own person
and live my new life as an adult and get
you know the thing that I need to pursue
my career or my passion or whatever it
is to find out that oh no no this is the
third or this is the fourth shooting or
whatever it might be
like the insanity that we can just sit
by and be like
we now have multiple accounts of
students who have now lived through more
than one school shooting
like that's just not acceptable that is
completely not it is unacceptable to
have that idea that now that's just
common that's it's not rare anymore
there's good news though Gabe Sanchez
because there's a High School Janitor
who has invented a new device that makes
it easy to clean up the Halls 10 times
faster
let me show you let me show you this new
device that they invented to clean up
the hallways of schools this is
something else let's watch this High
School Janitor invented a new way to
clean the Halls 10 times faster
[Music]
I don't know if you noticed what that
was yeah yeah um
that was a um a a device that picks up
shell casings off of a hallway floor
and it it exists now I don't know the
um
if this is actually if this is a parody
Or joke
um obviously making fun of the way that
we allow
the the actual invention of this device
to be invented by a janitor of a high
school to pick up shell casings off the
floor or in a mall or in a grocery store
really it's uh so I just looked it up
because I was curious myself on what
this was I think obviously it's um I
well I don't know the account I'm gonna
I'm gonna assume I'm going to if you're
gonna if you go to my now this is um
this account is um actually they are um
a PR person for Hassan this the Hun on
on Twitter but uh I saw an Avion yeah
yeah which so this is it's an existing
it's an existing product they have
actually multiple different kinds
they've got a different compact for
Rifle and Pistol brass but this one
specifically is ammo ammo up is the
company that makes this Rifle and Pistol
brass collector range cleanup tool 36
inches push picker
um I don't know how much it costs
because it's unavailable on Amazon
that's that's oh that's probably because
they're sold out
probably
but hey it's made in the USA you want
real and raw and it's and it's made in
the USA of course what other [__]
country would you make it in yeah you
wouldn't make it in the other country
they they wouldn't be able to sell it in
in civilized countries right we are the
only country with this problem where we
have to pick up thousands of rounds of
of am of uh shell casings
from semi-automatic rifles off Mall
floors off grocery store floors off
Church floors off school floors
Elementary School floors uh dance hall
floors
nightclub floors I mean this is a
problem we have so much so that we're
inventing machines
to rake up the shell casings off the
floors after mass shootings
it's a real [__] thing folks
I don't know of an actual janitor
invented this thing but obviously
we know what the account here is trying
to say about this device
um
and you know to walk away from it to not
talk about it and to not you know maybe
a lot of people are upset with me today
when I'm pointing the finger at
ourselves but
it is us who is doing this to us and you
want to say oh it's the gun nuts it's
gun nuts it's gun nuts they are us folks
we are them
we're all the government
we're all Americans and I and I hate it
because I don't both sides of this [__]
you know I don't because both sides are
not the same
you'll get you'll get tots and pears
from Ted Cruz who's got blood on his
hands because he he takes NRA money and
and genuflex at the altar of the gun
lobby
every Republican out there is
genuflecting at the altar of the gun
lobby there's no question who is for and
who is against
Common Sense regulation it's not [__]
rocket surgery
that we know who is for and who is
against gun regulation common sense [__]
simple [__] that the majority of
Americans want
but it is us who elect these
[__] it is us who put up with
this [__] because we don't engage in our
democracy
if you find someone that's sick and
tired a parent that's sick and tired of
hearing the story after Story and scared
to death of their children being sent to
an elementary school and being down by a
[__] weapon of war and then as they
grow up you're scared to send them to a
[__] University because you're scared
they're going to be mowed down by
semi-automatic handgun or semi-automatic
rifle and then you're scared if they're
gonna go to the grocery store
or if they're going to go if they're
going to go to church if you're if
you're terrified of that aspect and you
need to if you find that person you need
to talk to them and tell them tell them
the cold-blooded honest truth
and stop [__] pussy-footing around in
our democracy stop it
be responsible do your civic duty which
is engage and talk to people about these
issues it's most important you you sent
me a couple links here they're um
What's um what's is there breaking news
breaking news news okay what uh what do
we have for breaking news is this the
Matt gas thing yeah this is okay uh we
have breaking news on Matt Gantz I've
seen um someone else no wrong one yeah
no he had it right I think I don't know
that wasn't it wasn't it I don't know
that's a really news now are you gonna
are you gonna are you gonna hit it or am
I I'll hit it
live breaking news from the Tony
Michaels podcast it it seems as if
um the doj has officially decided not to
charge Matt gatson's sex in a sex
trafficking probe
um Is What It Seems
that's that's what we're getting
um from them now I mean this could mean
a lot of different things obviously this
is going to be disappointing to a lot of
people because this this [__]
this lying succubus is this [__]
swamp creature that is five head Matt
Getz venmo the venmo machine
um deserves every part of this
allegation to be penned to him for the
rest of his life and we can do that we
can indict him yeah yeah in the public
because these are allegations that are
real we we've seen the evidence when he
tried to hide his venmo you remember
that his venmo was public and he's like
oh [__] oh [__] I need to make it
private he's like I gotta stop paying
Joel Greenberg for a salad ice cream and
stuff
stuff how much does a salad cost when
you paid um
Joe Greenberg with I think a few hundred
it's like it's like a really expensive
salad it's a really expensive salad
because it's right you know does it come
with the cocaine Buffet uh that's it and
the underage in the underage uh girl uh
dessert is that does it come is that
salad come with that it's a it's like a
you buy this and then you're like oh
well you know you get two sides to pick
right
and that's typically what it is for him
right now I don't I don't want people to
be too discouraged about uh this this
piece of [__] not being criminally
charged because
um
um the guy was seeking a pardon so yeah
it wasn't just taking a pardon he was
seeking a pardon from uh now to the
beginning of time right well I mean you
know in case anyone would find out the
crimes that he's committed
um because I want you to also understand
that
even though he may have escaped the doj
at this point for these sex trafficking
charges
um there is no statute of limitation I
think federally for sex trafficking I
don't now the question is the other
charges and investigations right because
this this is the well this is the sex
trafficking probe
um and I haven't read this article but
based on what we're seeing so far it
looks like um the job Greenberg case
because um well here it is it's not very
long we'll just read this is from CNN
um if you can believe CNN this is why
I'm kind of skeptical of this but we'll
we'll go with it I mean it's been
reported by other places CNN first yeah
I think CNN was the first are they
confirming with the Department well here
we'll just read this the Department of
Justice has informed lawyers for at
least one witness
um that it will and I I would say it's
witnessing the case against him when you
say at least one witness
that it will not bring charges against
Florida GOP rep Matt gatz after the
years-long federal sex trafficking
investigation according sources familiar
with the matter senior officials reached
out to the lawyers for at least one
witness on Wednesday the source tells
CNN to inform them that the decision not
to prosecute gats
the final decision was made by the doj
leadership after investigators
recommended against charge charges last
year
so there it is there's your breaking
news Matt Gantz escapes escapes the
lasso one last time
um now again I don't I'm not sure of the
federal staff I'm not a [__] attorney
I'm not an attorney you're not I no no
didn't go to law school I actually
dropped out of college twice and you
want to know the truth [__] that [__]
um here's here's the deal though I I do
not think that um there are federal
statutes of limitations on sex
trafficking Maybe I'm Wrong on that
um I'd have checked that out I know New
York has changed some of their laws
around that but we'd have to check that
out
but and it looks like Gabe Sanchez is
doing that right now uh maybe or he's
looking at something else he's like uh
Tony's oh [__] out of fact check this
[__] in real time he's always
trying to fact check me I'm I'm just
looking to I'm I'm I'm looking through
because obviously like the freshest
takes are gonna be on Twitter so I'm
trying to see if there's any like
lawyers out there who are giving their
oh I see they're two cents yeah should
we should we see if uh Ben myzealous
wants to chime in on this or not I mean
you can who knows he's probably
recording some video right now he might
be um but you can ping him to see if he
wants to talk about it live
um here on the Tony Michaels podcaster
if he wants to wait to do it on their
Channel
um some of the other news is this
trained derailment if you if you uh
check with him if he wants to talk more
about the Matt gassing
the train derailment now
um obviously a lot of people are going
to be mad at me why she's still [__]
what the f why in the [__] is Nikki
Haley Nikki Haley is still trending it
is pissing me what the [__] is he's
trending down dude she's trending she's
number two what I don't know man you
know all I gotta say is the the Twitter
algorithm is a [__] [__] show right
now oh I definitely want to talk about
Elon e oh yeah whenever you want to dig
into that oh man I'm happy to
uh here's the here's the Nikki Haley
thread of course Patriot takes all all
the evidence that Nikki Haley is a
hypocrite as if you needed a lot of
evidence in the first place like what
evidence did you need besides she was on
stage remember when she was on stage
with Little Marco and she's like oh my
God no one would ever in their right
mind vote for Donald Trump he's a fraud
and then she's like yeah I'll be your
U.N Ambassador you goddamn right I will
like what more how far do you have to go
to collect evidence that Nikki Haley is
just a typical Republic looking like
Santos yeah like she's a line sack of
[__] she's a republican I mean they're
all they're all lines they are
Republicans they are Republicans
um let's see what what the [__] is is
this is this from her launch today
Aaron rupar has something oh well I must
I must mock this because here is an old
white nut sack I mean if there if there
is like an image of old fat white
Republican Trump supporter this is it
look at this this guy I bet he claims to
be a pastor somewhere too what do you
think I don't even know who the [__]
this is to be quite honest but I bet I
bet this [__] cleans me he's
like he looks like Newt Gingrich before
Newt Gingrich lost weight
this guy this guy looks like he would
sexually harass or assault you right
this guy will grip you all at the same
time yeah no this guy looks like if
you're at a family dinner he would
definitely take all of your food right
exactly and he would probably pull money
out of the offering plate and hit the
church that he has just sticky hands
going in for this this is like Joel
Olsteen in 60 years oh he's standing
right here right here I don't know who
this is can we find out who this is
because I really want to know if we're
like spot on let's listen while while
you see if this is only 21 seconds I
don't know what this is I have no idea
what this is gonna say let's let's
listen
Our Father
matured in heaven Creator did do what
what uh our father
yeah who what in heaven who Pastor John
Hagee oh my God oh my God I was spot on
right yeah I did I swear to God I did
not know I swear to the God that I don't
believe in that I did not know that he
was going to start the [__] Lord's
Prayer I had no idea now me and gave her
a group of Catholic and I know a lot of
people probably grew up saying saying
the Our Father this is not this is not
the uh yeah this is a difference I mean
he started off he started here and then
he switched this is weird this is weird
listen listen to the listen to the words
Our Father
matured in heaven creator of Heaven and
Earth
the Mighty God who calls the Stars by
name
who holds the seven seas and the palms
of his hand
who breathed into dust on Creations
mourning yeah this is not the answer
I have no idea this is some other this
is his this is him
this is this is uh some other some other
take I don't know this is like a this is
like a custom this is a John Hagee
special
uh okay here's a video that here's what
here's what Aaron says now I was
wondering if it was like Aaron's feed
but you guys know that Aaron provides a
lot of Clips uh for the for the internet
he says Nikki Haley's campaign he's
launched events beginning begins with
prayer and poor sound quality I know you
heard the buzz but that is apparently
feed into the actual audio this isn't
like Aaron is pulling the clip from some
obscure place and the audio's [__] up
this was actually their sound quality on
on God damn they are so horrible at this
it's pretty bad it's pretty bad I mean
look if you can't say the Our Father
correctly
uh what are you doing out there man I I
know it's pretty [__] simple what
church is this guy from he's he's from
so uh
uh he I'm looking up what church right
now
but uh I just sent you another link when
right wing watch quote tweeted uh this
is and this is his own like little
televangelist Hagee hotline because of
course of course he has one
right right well yeah he's got a grift I
mean we said this I mean again he looks
like the wish.com it almost looks like
and just bear with me here and I know
this is going to put a lot of bad images
in people's heads but it almost looks
like newt Gingers and Donald Trump
[__] and had a baby and that baby is
now an evangelist on TV is it with the
red tie and the stupid yeah I could see
it did you see it
oh this is this is Newt Gingrich and
Donald Trump's baby
oh my God they're [__] man child what
the [__] is this let's listen the
Supreme Court in Washington has handed
down it's fi its decision in a 5-4
ruling supporting same-sex marriage but
the Supreme Court in heaven has handed
down its unanimous decision and a 3-0
ruling from God the Father Son and Holy
Spirit recorded in the Book of Genesis
chapter 2 24 stating therefore shall a
man leave his father and mother and
plead to his wife and they twain shall
be one flesh marriage is exclusively
between a man and a woman oh he's a
bigot who would have guessed
my name's John Hagee and I'm a bigot
I mean who would have guessed who would
have guessed if Donald Trump Newt
Gingrich [__] had a baby that it'd be
a bigot who would have guessed that holy
[__] God damn this is this is something
else and this is apparently the person
who's gonna stand between Donald Trump
and Nikki Haley as he rips her apart
this is going to be fantastic man I
don't I don't know how to tell you
people this so oh my God this warms my
heart this warms my heart that the Civil
War that is about to take place in the
Republican party and this is only more
proof only more proof of why Rhonda
Santos will not get in I almost bet that
Donald Trump by the end of the week by
the end of the weekend is [__] just
railing on this guy and he's gonna find
any [__] thing he can about this son
of a [__] this what's his name Hagman
haggy haggar John Hagee Hagee no okay I
don't know I mean look it's [__] it's
gonna if this ends up being like a
pastor [__] Face-Off right yeah or
it's him versus the Paula Michelle white
cane yeah who can out dig it the bigot
is that again and again and again and
again and again and again that could be
a good game show that could be a good
game show big how big it the bigot it
could be a really good game show
America's top favorite game show who's
the biggest biggest
I think we got a top show right there we
can even play it on Fox you know yeah
well I think they would pick it up I
think they would I think all the trader
TVs they'd be like oh big it I love this
Jesus Christ are you telling me we're
gonna we're gonna despairish minorities
on a game show and people are gonna win
money doing it let's do that I just want
to see I just want to see the the
Trump's Pastor she's like again she gets
hit in the buzzer again and again and
again and they're like okay
we get it so is it like America's Got
Talent where like they have the judges
and then someone comes out to be a bigot
and then they have to judge rather than
being a big enough like there's gonna be
there's gonna be someone who's on stage
who's like I'm the host right and then
you've got the judges who are over there
and and then yeah they decide who yeah
right America's biggest and then and
then all the moglodytes get to call in
and vote or who goes to Mar-A-Lago like
the biggest bigot who goes tomorrow yeah
or what we do is we do like the Biggest
Loser Like We Do a reboot you know and
it's the big biggest bigot and in there
every week you know because like they
would typically be like oh how many
pounds did you lose this week right it's
like how much more money can they get
yeah how many like how many uh how many
racial slurs how many races slurs that
he said how many uh marginalized
communities did you put down how many
you know uh how many how many how many
hate tweets you said how many people did
you offend you know like how how and
then and then there's probably
competitions like in one sentence how
many different cultures and groups can
you offend right
I don't know I think we got gold here on
the right wing we could totally make a
ton of money and then it's just donate
it all to to I don't know the lgbtq
community I mean I think it's all I
think it's pretty
pretty safe bet that if you just donate
to an lgbtq or like the ACLU or
something like that they you know they
[__] lose their [__] because like oh
no wait I don't wanna do
shouldn't have the same
right but they would be voting for the
biggest bigot like crazy even though
they know the one he's going towards it
oh I love that bigot
I love me some bigots
all right let's listen let's listen to
the last part of this bigot same-sex
marriage will never be accepted in
heaven as legitimate so says God
Almighty you know I don't think
um um people the lgbtq community or
their allies give a flying [__] if gay
marriage is accepted and have do you do
you think they give a [__] I don't I
don't give a [__] I could care less what
God thinks I honestly uh I'm I'm I got
my own [__] to deal with right right
like my jokes [__] business there
yeah I can tell you right now that uh
I'm already [__] dealing with my own
[__] I do not have any interest to get
into someone else's [__] right and
tell them what to do like look I again
my day busy I procrastinate I do this I
got this I wish I could do other things
I got all this [__] to deal with
adhds yeah I don't need other people's
[__] well you know what's you know
what's crazy it's like a lot of people
who have never been married don't
understand that marriage is like it's a
it's a partnership it's work like you
got to work together to solve problems
and you know make it through the world
together any partnership whether you're
married or not if you're committed
there's a partnership there and like you
know why why on Earth why on Earth would
I want to worry about someone else's
partnership and their marriage when I'm
really you should be focused on your own
it really kind of projects the trouble
that you're having let's let's see what
um Newt Trump has but there's something
I do want to point out yeah really
quickly he brings up the fact that uh
this is not accepted right because of
God right right but I'm pretty sure
pretty sure the pope also recently
denounced anti-gay laws right like yeah
but years ago yeah is he really a
god-like figure I mean this guy I'm
saying this guy probably hates him some
Catholic like he hates him some games if
there was anyone who was the closest
person to God you know I'm not saying
God exists because I don't believe well
that's because you were deluded as a as
a child by Catholicism look I mean at
the end of the day right we were mind
[__] by Catholicism so you got that
kind of idea I mean this guy was not
mine but crucifix was like right in my
[__] right you know right right but
I'll tell you I'll tell you this much
yeah it no lube uh I'll tell you this
much that's what the sound is that's
yeah it would be there would be no sound
if it was good it sounds like the grape
stomp lady
um for anyone anyone early to the
internet days uh I don't want to date
myself here oh [__] but the pope himself
right the all you know you've got other
people who are in leadership Pastor
positions what now like they are
against these anti-lgbtq laws they're
they're against these anti-laws right
and he even said he even said two weeks
ago
the pope said Pope Francis
homosexuality isn't a crime
verbatim said that he said that he said
it wasn't a crime
I can't wait it's not the you know look
they could be even more Progressive but
he's making he's making waves 2020 2021
2023 announcing these things of like
gay marriage isn't a sin
these laws are are terrible and also if
you're gay it's not bad it is not bad be
who you are be who you want to be God
will love you regardless pretty sure the
Bible says that well you know I think a
hog head here that this that Pastor hog
head here I think once once he gets up
to the old pearly gates and the three
Supreme justices the the father Son and
Holy Spirit are standing there and
they're like why did you disparage your
other fellow humans you know why would
you do that's assuming he even gets past
the Pearly Gates because at the Pearly
Gates he has to he has to he has to go
through the list and and actually get
checked right like you have Saint Peter
at the Pearly Gates it's a big [__]
all the all the things even though so
you don't you don't even think he gets
past the gate guys oh okay I will say
this in the visuals I've seen of the
Pearly Gates of Heaven it looks like
Donald Trump's wall because on either
side you can just cross over have you
fact checked have you fact checked these
images I'm just wondering know I'm just
saying these are the images I saw in my
grandparents home growing up and it was
the Pearly gate Saint Peter and then you
know Jesus and the light was behind the
Gates once they opened these are your
Catholic grandparents yeah there was a
big there was also a big photo of Jesus
a white jesus white jesus white Jesus
with his hipster beard and his long hair
and heavy right as you walk down the
street oh they're they're really they're
really rebounding branding Jesus he's no
longer like white Jesus he's like white
Jim bro Jesus have you seen this no I
haven't all the depictions thyroids well
I mean yeah I mean Jesus why would you
need to he's got the Holy Spirit
Well that is the Holy Spirit you know
he's on gear right he's on here oh dude
he's not he's not yo he's on gear he's
on a step oh yeah sure dude right no
[__] and it's the Holy Spirit that's
jacking him up from bologna sandwich man
right guys [__] right now
let's let's listen to hog head here
Pastor hogging let's see what else he
has to say about how bigoted he is this
supreme court has made America the new
Sodom and Gomorrah God will have to
judge America or he's going to have to
apologize to Sodom and Gomorrah oh my
God he's [__] gay uh he he thinks
he's just going to tell God what to do
and that's funny also it's just God like
God is just only focus on America he's
like look I know there's like seven plus
billion people almost 8 billion is that
right are we close to eight do we hit no
we're over eight we're over overeating
baby goddamn babies all the time man
babies everywhere right but we're over
eight billion people now on this planet
and
he thinks that God is like look man my
favorite child is America like uh I
don't think that's how that works also
I'm pretty sure that America is the
child that God wished was never born he
probably was like man I wish America was
[__] aborted I'll tell you that much
if every day there's a there's some new
mass shooting or Republicans try to [__]
over the poor or the people who actually
need help by not providing housing or
not providing food or trying to cut
subsidized programs or social programs
that would help those people the very
people that the scripture of the Bible
says that we should look out for I'm
pretty sure if God looked at at America
he's like God damn should have should
have aborted that one I swear should
have taken Plan B should have should
have stopped it even before was even a
chance
well speaking of a possible abortions
um I guess Nikki Haley took the stage as
well and she was talking about and
spoken Nikki Haley watching presidential
bid in Charleston
I don't know maybe maybe the audio is
better in this one yeah
I mean that that's probably what it
sounds like I don't know it sounds a
little like uh like a little bit like
Gollum yeah well you know like smeagle
you know well Chicago looks like oh
let's let's play it
When I Look To The Future I see America
strong once more we'll end inflation and
build an economy that works for all just
like we did in South Carolina she is
such a dumb [__] did you hear
what she end inflation you stupid you
you brainless mindless [__] you people
who have no [__] clue how any economy
Works in any capitalist Society at all
you're going to what do away with
inflation you think prices are never
going to rise what the [__] is wrong
with her
this is this oh this is this is great
this is great folks because everyone
wants to talk about her hypocrisy let's
talk about her [__] stupidity and how
we can mock how [__] ignorant Nikki
Haley is she's going to end this is like
saying you're going to end abortion
you're going to end inflation what the
[__] is wrong with you I mean I mean it
goes the same way as the Republicans who
like oh Joe Biden is controlling the
inflation it's like oh actually
inflation is a global concept and
something that has to be done within the
global economy there are there are
especially especially when it's Global
inflation that is happening right and
he's the one he's the one oh I see we
have a fan over here Dan Cobin Gabe why
are you still here
also it's not a question he just says
Gabe why are you still here period Well
you know I mean he probably thinks that
you can end inflation for good as well
like he believes uh we need to put it
into inflation for good like do you have
any idea out okay let me give you let me
give you let me give you a hint
the reason why our unemployment is so
[__] low right and our employment is
so [__] high and the stock market
still is at record levels right and our
economy is not bad
because of inflation okay so if you were
alive and which most of you I'm sure
were back in 2008
you remember what deflation felt like in
the economy I don't know if you've ever
been in a deflated economy like a real
like [__] nosedive economy but here's
the thing the reason why corporations
because the majority of inflation is
[__] fake anyways the reason why the
majority of inflation is happening is
because people are still buying I don't
know if you heard this news Don I don't
know if you heard this news Nikki Haley
you stupid [__]
retail sales went up three percent in
January
consumer confidence is not going
anywhere inflation is not the issue you
stupid [__] it is listen listen to me
listen to me if inflation was really
that bad in our economy
sales would not be going up people would
not be people would not have confidence
in their buying power you dumb
[__] the reason why they have
confidence in about buying power is
because our country is fully employed
under Joe Biden
he has set up the economy in a way and
and that the legislator our legislative
body the re the the nothing to do with
Republicans the house in this Democratic
Senate in this 117th Congress provide us
with the coveted relief funds which set
our economy on track set our economy on
track and with the infrastructure built
is going to set our economy even on
better on track over the next 10 years
you stupid [__] this this brain dead
[__] to try to Gaslight people
into thinking that you can make it to
where inflation doesn't exist right this
is really stupid this is really stupid
and I dare you to go tell someone who
owns a shitload of real estate a rich
[__] that owns a shitload of
real estate go try to tell them that
they should be voting against inflation
like how do you think how do you think
so many people built what built wealth
over the last two years they own
property they're in prop they're
property inflated anything let's not
forget the fact that you know when it
comes to the actual economics of of of
what we have going on here especially
with inflation actually a little bit of
inflation is not yeah not that bad a
little bit it's actually good it's good
it's recommended right right obviously
not high inflation and not you won't
want zero but a little bit of inflation
is actually good the reason that Don
Cobin is upset I see here is because he
said that I think America should have
been aborted tell me I'm
if you looked at America as a baby and
you looked at all the [__] [__] that
it's doing right now the way that it's
acting out the way that it's being a
[__] petulant child that has taken
away rights killing other people and not
wanting to actually love its neighbor
tell me that the people in control right
now especially in the house actually
care for this the last four years we had
Donald Trump Don Coleman tell me that if
you look back and you're like man
Don Coleman would have been better if we
had just been you know what honestly
that's why it's like whatever these
flying objects that are coming into our
airspace [__] take me now dude Beam
Me Up probe me take me out of this
situation because the [__] is [__] up
Don but it doesn't mean that I won't
fight it Don quit being a [__] ass
[__] quit I mean I saw someone I saw
someone else that said Don is a Pap stop
being a [__] ass [__] he says six and
a half that's a little bit at 6.5 that's
a little bit listen listen Don if you're
if you're upset about
um Biden's inflation destroying the
economy wait till you find out what
Republicans want to do with the national
debt and wait till you find out how they
want to destroy the economy by shutting
down the government wait till you find
out about that I bet you're gonna be
super pissed I bet you're actually
cheering when the economy tanks because
they're trying to do that let's go back
let's go back to the brilliant Economist
here Nikki [__] Haley
[Applause]
in the America I see every child gets a
world-class education because every
parent gets to pick their child's School
oh this is really stupid too oh my God
this is so stupid
so you expect
their their children's education look we
got a lot of [__] parents in this
country that should not have anything to
do with with what [__] what their
kids are being educated on that's why we
actually have public schools that's why
we have public curriculum that's why we
put professionals and we put people who
know what the [__] they're doing in
charge of that curriculum not their
[__] parents listen to me when I tell
you this listen to me when I do this now
there are exceptions to this rule
but and and the exceptions are people
who have to homeschool their children
it's a must but if you homeschool your
children on your own choice of your own
you are indoctrinating them
let me repeat that
if you are homeschooling your children
of your own volition it's not it's not a
necessity that you have to do
you are indoctrinating your children
against actual professional curriculum
you know what do I know what what is
what is this um oh I was just bringing
up stuff people bringing out you know
you know okay
um
Don Coban
uh look at look look Don
um now
you heard yeah I said something right it
went in your ear and and you heard what
you wanted to hear now what I said was a
little bit of inflation was good I never
said the current rate of inflation is
good obviously we should go lower but if
you listen to what I literally said
I said based on the economics of
everything going on especially with
inflation you can roll back the tape
[__] yeah yeah rewind what I
said rewind I said a little bit of
inflation economists say a little bit of
inflation is good you don't want zero
you want a little bit of inflation I
never said right now our current
inflation level is what we want
again go back I said something you heard
something else it seems to be a pattern
here Don yeah Don Cobin let's Don
let's let's continue with the the
economic and education expert Nikki
Haley let's continue with her expertise
here on the stage let's see
and no politician will be able to close
those schools ever again
oh that's a fantastic I mean the people
you mean the Republican party oh man the
one that's taking books out and well I
would assume soon enough they'll be
burning dictionaries you know you know
who closed Gabe you know who closed
schools
in the states where Republicans were
Governors do you know who
you know close them
it was probably Republicans oh okay okay
okay it was probably Republicans it was
probably Republicans you know what you
know what's also funny is that you're
gonna actually tie hands behind people's
back because she's saying politicians
I'm guessing she means like school board
members
um so what she's gonna do is she's gonna
make it to where even if you elect
people to make the right decisions that
you don't get to help those people make
the right decisions because what Nikki
Haley and these [__] boneheads in
this audience don't understand is they
elect people to run their public schools
because it is a bureaucracy it is a
government it is the public school the
whole point of public schools is so the
community regardless
if you have children in that school or
not if you have children in the school
and you own property more than likely
you pay taxes to that school or if you
don't have children but you actually
have a vote you have a vote towards the
school board so that you can I don't
know
have the say in your school that's your
say is your vote for school board so I
doubt that these people understand what
she's saying but what she's saying is we
don't want your vote to count
we we I want to dictate from the
presidency
what you're is going to happen in your
Schools she's talking about autocracy
and education I mean it's the same it
sounds a little bit similar to what
Trump was talking about like you notice
that she has to most likely she has to
align with the talking points of trump
right she and then well no she's gonna
have to do one she's got one or two days
she's gonna have to either go to the
right of trump or the left of trump
right but I can tell you right now base
I mean if you remember last week he was
talking about coming after or uh coming
coming after the lgbtq community he was
uh talking about you know coming after
he was going to dictate this curriculum
he was gonna exactly through that tape
so it's it's very similar now we're
gonna find out because again she only
announced what yesterday right two days
ago yeah and this this is in the last
few hours that she's right and so we're
gonna find almost every time which way
you know of if we if we look at Trump as
the BET The Benchmark right the middle
ground Benchmark the [__] the [__] ass
[__] Mark that's what we're gonna
figure out
we need to talk about the [__] ass
[__] right now so we're gonna find out
either yeah like we said on the right or
left but you know it right now she's
aligning with the same same politics
because I think what she's trying to do
is she's trying to say Hey look
you like what he says I also have those
things and she's trying to bring people
over and then potentially say okay this
is where I'm gonna I'm gonna shift and
I'm gonna either go more right wing or
I'm gonna go a little bit less to get
other people on the on the center
but we bring a [__] ass [__] and we've
talked about [__] ass [__] a few times
on the show but the the number one
other than Trump [__] ass [__] that we
need to talk about is Elon Musk the
owner of the bird app Twitter
[__] ass [__] this guy I don't know I
don't let me I'm gonna pull up uh you
know why you're doing I want to tell the
audience because me and Gabe had a
conversation I said I think I'm going to
uh substitute anytime I want to say
snowflake because I know we say it in
the in the intro but anytime I want to
say snowflake I'm going to insert [__]
ass [__] here on out here
three hours Tony yeah I mean it's look
we're getting there three hours costs
money okay yeah hang on tight we're
getting there okay well two hours cost a
lot of [__] money but three hours
yeah it does it's just that much more
what's this what's this okay so this is
the this is the tweet that I sent you
last night right
this is oh yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
right so this is if so I thought he
banned been gallons
um I don't know I don't know okay now I
haven't even when he's reported against
him several times right right there's a
great people and they're all bringing up
this story now so I don't know if people
remember but on Tuesday we were talking
about Elon and I said is it just you
guys
or or sorry is it just me or were your
Twitter feeds also full of Elon tweets
and you guys like the whole thing it's
like you know it's like a pinball
machine on someone else and then
and and then yesterday I came across
this tweet and then read the article
about what happened and the reason that
me and Tony in Texas Paul and other
people watching who are on Twitter
got all of elon's tweets as I prioritize
and everyone else was just like
suppressed
was because Elon
on Super Bowl night saw that Joe Biden's
tweet was outperforming his
and Elon with his small little [__] ass
[__] ego got so butt hurt
that he had his cousin hold an emergency
meeting with with engineers at Twitter
to read
why is cousin wait why is that was the
thing I was like what the [__] James
mustard because he's the only people who
are who are in the like the board and
all the only other people that are like
within or not because it actually like
the power structure but within the power
structure it's you know brother cousin
uh he's got some people from uh older
people are you [__] me it's all
nepotism it's one of them all the people
that he's worked with and also family
members are the ones that are in these
you see the problem do you see the
problem here with this story is it
starts out with elon's cousin James musk
vent to the will of his cousin who has
44 billion dollars about Twitter and
probably pays him an ass load of money
to to capitulate to him this is
on his way out on his oh yeah 100 a huge
huge problem a huge is this is this you
think this is real that he was he was he
was [__] butt hurt because yeah Joe
Biden's tweets were doing better than
his because yeah there's a whole there's
a whole breakdown an article about it
and basically there are also other
people they were engineers who have come
forward now to be like I was fired
because there I think it was two two
Engineers specifically there in the
article they were talking about oh they
got fired because Elon was like I've got
120 million followers and my my tweets
aren't doing so well you know this and
that and then they looked into it and
they're like there's no suppression
going off there's no you just suck and
it sucks to suck yeah like what what are
you gonna do it it just your tweets
aren't doing well and it happens to be a
trend with right wing uh Talking Heads
on Twitter
and it's it's just the fact that people
don't want to see your [__] and so when
they basically gave him an answer that
it wasn't it wasn't uh malicious content
malicious act again wait wait I want to
predict this I want to predict this yeah
I bet he's a [__] ass [__]
what did he do what did he do after he
found this out what did he do so then he
had so then basically he had this
emergency meeting that was run to have
the engineers reconfigure the algorithm
so that his tweet and his tweets could
get even more as he as he said the the
Twitter had Engineers rush to change
Twitter's algorithm to ensure Elon got
previously unheard of promotion right
like just bombard people even if you
don't follow them even if you blocked
him these are P this isn't this is an
account that got priority to just hit
your feed and show you everything
because the thing that he was
complaining about so he he timeline
raped us is that what you're saying and
yeah I mean it you know uh in so many
words yes that is what he did I'm just
trying to find a good way to describe it
he forced himself onto US onto our
Twitter timeline and this is one of
those things because the problem here
this is the most significant thing by
the way right here go ahead yeah yeah so
uh yeah after musk threatened to fire
his remaining Engineers they built a
system designed to ensure that musk and
musk alone benefits from previously
unheard of promotion of his tweets to
the entire user base so they basically
they held he held their jobs at gunpoint
yeah
fix this problem because what he had
realized and was it really a prop was it
a problem that we weren't seeing is
doing really I mean we also like he saw
it as a problem he's like I've got 120
million
following any sense because what
happened was when Elon made a new he he
revealed a new insight right it was the
views how many people view this tweet
and then you look at that to say like
how many people and it's well it was
always that way it's just now it's
public for everyone right everyone could
well you could see it was you know it's
close to the Impressions I mean they've
slightly changed things but for the most
part it's the idea that now you can see
how many how many eyeballs see this
tweet and then that shows you how many
people scrolled by and decided not to
quote tweet quote or like it right and
elon's world he thinks that every view
should equal a like and he saw that the
ratio was incredibly off but what Elon
doesn't [__] understand is there's
something called and I've said it before
on the show it's called the 99 one
principle meaning that 90 of the users
on a given platform are going to be
people who just have it and they lurk
around they follow accounts
and that's it nine percent will follow
they'll look around they might like
something they might comment on
something but they're not very active
they're just looking and then you've got
one percent the very highly active
people right like Tony and I or other
people here out in the audience who are
liking retweeting commenting and there's
people again who are like super users
who are beyond the top one percent of
the one percent you know right like they
like they engage way more than I do and
so Elon doesn't understand the fact that
not everyone on Twitter is going to
engage with your content because it
depends on where they fall in those
brackets and Elon thinks it should be a
100 you 100 of people follow me 100 of
people should like my [__]
and the engineers are like it doesn't
work that way and that's you can't
change human behavior online so I think
I think the next step for Elon and Elon
call me man I got some great ideas for
you to be the biggest [__] ass [__]
there is on Twitter really I got some
great ideas for you the one idea that I
have for you is for everyone to
automatically like your tweets like when
you go down to scroll you know when you
go down to scroll the feed and you're
like wait I've already seen that tweet
and it shows that you liked and retweet
it you're like why is it re-showing me
this I already [__] I already [__]
retweeted this I don't want to see it
again I'm just showing it to other
people I Elon look and I got a lot more
ideas other than this for you to be king
[__] ass [__] I know you got a lot of
competition in your little right-wing
Circle I mean I bet you could be king
ding-a-ling over there and [__] ass
[__] land if you just call me but I one
idea I want to give away to you for free
is that you should have every single
user like every one of your tweets
automatically like all of them like just
boom Everyone likes your tweets and make
you feel good inside it'll make you not
feel like a [__] ass [__] yeah
it'll help your ego a bit but part of me
thinks like if I knew that everyone just
automatically like my [__] it comes to
the question of like do people really
like me and the answer is no Elon nobody
[__] likes you outside of the Sims
that are guzzling you you mean you mean
the other [__] ass [__] yeah the
mini the mini [__] ass [__] right
right the gym bro 2-way mini [__] ass
[__] right those are yeah those are
the people the roganites the moglodytes
yeah the the Don cobins of the world oh
my God damn Tobin Don I'm glad you're
here every day I'm glad you're here
every day I'm glad you're subscribed to
the Tony Michaels podcast as you should
be as everyone should be you know what
this is a great idea we should make it
to where every one of our use I'm gonna
call YouTube here later on I'm gonna
make sure that they make sure that our
our our show is liked by every single
user and that it's yeah we can put it in
the timeline I'm just going to call them
and see get the [__] ass [__]
treatment over there at YouTube
um go ahead and follow us on elon's
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod follow our
personal accounts too and to download
every single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify and
Google don't forget to like us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels and also
you can watch us on the upwire.com their
YouTube channel go to upwire.com and go
to their YouTube channel and if you're
over on Twitch make sure you enter in
your Amazon Prime account that way you
don't get commercials over on Twitch if
you're watching on Twitch and if you got
an Amazon Prime account
and you don't use twitch go sign up on
your Prime account on Twitch and
description because you get one free
subscription over on Twitch that'll help
us out if you go sign up with your Prime
account and give us the subscription
every month GD Tony Michaels podcast it
helps us out here and also do not forget
to follow
and um Gabe Sanchez what was that
[Music]
that's really long it is I can change it
well you know what we need we need one
without sound so we can tell oh yeah I
can I'll I'll upload it without sounds
that way we could talk yeah yeah people
can go to patreon.com
I am Gabe Sanchez or you can go to what
was that show.com it'll take you right
back there I will have a new episode
dropping uh tonight I think uh so make
sure to do they get early Clips or
something yeah you get you get early
early Clips I also just added a little
background um I've started to add the
intro so you'll know exactly what the
context of the episode will be about
um so yeah there's other things that
I've got planned you can go to the
patreon again what was that show.com and
you can see all of the different
brackets on what things you want and
what access you want and it's all there
and while you're out there at patreon go
visit my page I'm almost I'm I had a
goal of a hundred and I didn't know I'd
get there this fast but we're like um
let's see I think I'm within 20. yeah
while you're over on patreon go check
out my page patreon.com the Tony
Michaels check it out over there be be a
member of the [__] them fam and you're
all member of the [__] man even Don
even Don hey Don Cobin you [__] them you
[__] em fam member you you [__] I mean
he subscribed he's here every day
I'm pretty sure I've seen Don Kobe oh
he's here oh yeah he's here oh something
else new something else new we have the
Surf's Up [__] merch over at
store.thetonymichaels.com that store not
the Tony michaels.com the new Surf's Up
[__]
shirt and this morning Gabe Sanchez I
put on the coffee mug so you can not
only get a shirt now you get a coffee
mug and I promise we're coming with the
pab45 we're probably gonna have two
designs and I'm gonna have another
Surf's Up design so if you're waiting on
those I understand but why not why not
own them all why not own them all it
helps us out here at the Tony Michaels
podcast that way we can get to that
third hour these hours are not free but
they are to you they are to you every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch do not forget
to subscribe here on YouTube and we
simulcast from the Midas touch Facebook
page same time same place tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them
foreign
[Music]